et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
julien bayou bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane je me suis
dirigeant et julien bayou on va
commencer avec ses premiers pas du
gouvernement castex comment vous le
qualifiez vous gouvernement castex un
gouvernement de droite de fin de mandat
pour le dire tout simplement c'est à
dire que c'est un premier ministre de
droite qui succède un premier ministre
de droite
et c'est la fin de mandat c'est à dire
qu'il reste 18 mois un budget car quand
à l'automne on aura le dernier budget
comme on dit utile c'est-à-dire que qui
couvrira l'année 2021 et on en attend
malheureusement pas grand chose il fait
il ya une feuille de route c'est la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
c'est ça nous attentes moi je le redis
au premier ministre lundi qui la
courtoisie républicaine de m'appeler
nous on vous attend sur une chose la
transcription en acte de ces
propositions
il ya un tel retard en matière climat
biodiversité et justice sociale que ces
propositions se sont celles qui peuvent
créer des emplois soulager le
porte-monnaie et puis sert face aux
idées répandues et là il m'a pas rassuré
voilà pour je vais pas 3g pas trahir nos
échanges j'imagine qu'il en dira
peut-être un mot lors de la politique
générale c'est ça ma crainte c'est qu'il
en dise qu'un mot nous nous voulons des
actes jusqu'ici il a dit une phrase sur
l'écologie pour dire que ce n'était pas
une option
c'était une obligation l'écologie n'est
pas une obligation c'est un peu faible
c'est un peu courtes un peu court
exactement et et puis surtout en fait
des mots des mots on en a plein nous on
veut des actes
oui alors il ya eu quand même quelques
gages tout de même il y avait eu raison
des engagements de d'examiner les 146
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le pour le climat une ligue la
nomination d'une nouvelle ministre de la
transition écologique barbara pompili
auquel vous avez souhaité bon vent
bon courage et surtout fait lé bon
courage probablement mai
vous avez aussi dit qu'elle vous
espériez qu'elle fasse mieux que son
passage comme secrétaire d'état la
bienvenue à c'était sous françois
hollande vous doutez considérablement de
sa marge de manoeuvre
ben oui complète complètement s'il
voulait elle était en 2016 secrétaire
d'état dans un gouvernement qui était
pas fondamentalement écolo et c'était la
fin de mandat donc qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire
vous êtes en fait un peu en train de
gérer les affaires courantes là on se
retrouve un peu dans la même
configuration
quand vous avez le ministre de
l'économie qui n'est pas écolo quand
vous avez le premier ministre qui n'est
pas écolo mois l'a jamais entendu le
castex sur les questions d'écologie
quand vous avez le président qui ne
mesurent pas vraiment le défi auquel on
est confronté et bien une ministre de
l'écologie tout aussi convaincu sincère
et le rang protocolaire qui va bien et
c'est en vérité ne pèse pas c'est la
triste expérience comme l'a fait nicolas
hulot qui était beaucoup plus populaires
et qui était ministre d'état
même sur les plus petits arbitrage même
sur sur des sujets sur lesquels la la
population est massivement en attente de
changement je pense à la condition
animale
même là dessus ça bloque vous aurez noté
malgré tout qu'elle à être deux
ministres délégués ont été adjoints à la
ministre de la transition écologique
logement et transport ça résonne quand
même comme un signal oui encore
invaincue vraiment nourrir on n'est pas
dans une posture politicienne vraiment
tout ce qu'il y aura dans mon sens on
appuiera vraiment il n'ya pas donc ça va
dans le bon sens il n'y a pas de calcul
publié les sujets c'est comme avec un
instant il ya enfin vous voyez en 2002
le ministère la transition écolo avait
déjà un périmètre assez large que si
vous vous souvenez qui s'était c'était
borloo comme at-il fait voyez enfin il a
changé les led
les ampoules au ministère nous voulons
des actes profond structurants et ça
c'est la transcription en acte de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat le
président a dit qu'il est passé sans
filtre et immédiatement derrière les
différents ministres se sont succédé
pour dire qu en fait celle ci sur la pub
on aller par l'appliquer la baisse de la
tva sur les transports en commun on
n'allait pas l'appliquer on sait bien
pourtant le train allait et françaises
et les français sont devant leur side
leur site internet pour prendre des
billets on voit bien que le train il est
trop cher
évidemment et donc il faut en baisser le
prix ont favorisé lusage la liste est
trop longue
si vous voulez de toutes ses promesses
qui ne sont jamais suivies d'effet il ya
un une mesure structurante la rénovation
thermique pour oui effectivement de la
ministe de l'écologie et la main sur le
logement
très bien simplement il faut mettre les
budgets voyez c'est même plus une
question de loi pour le coup là les
acteurs sont prêts il y avait juste
besoin de du budget de volonté politique
la rue lajoie ségur delà de
l'environnement le secteur de la santé
ça a l'air de pas mal marché on va on y
retourne non mais c'est quoi c'est une
prochaine concertation pour ensuite
tirer les leçons d'un grand débat qui
débouchera peut-être sur une nouvelle
convention pour ensuite quand est-ce
qu'on agit en fait beau ici vont
clairement vous êtes à ces défaitistes
il ne se passera rien sur les coups de
lame est vraiment fin du mois lequel je
l'espère vraiment parce que si vous
voulez si on vaut rien si on vous
rénovez votre logement vous payez moins
cher en hiver et vous c'est plus
confortable en est et or qui en a besoin
les plus vulnérables c'est une mesure de
justice sociale
ça crée de l'emploi local non
délocalisables et pas pour les gros pour
les pme pour les artisans pour les
apprentis fins et tous corps de métier
on est face à une crise économique
d'ampleur et là on a besoin voilà
rénover le bâti c'est la promesse de
centaines de milliers d'emplois
gaël giraud il parle d un demi million
d'emplois pour ce qui est de la
rénovation du bâtiment public qu'est-ce
qu'on attend voiliers et puis alors pour
le climat s'est vraiment passé le coeur
de l'action la limitation des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre du bâti et c'est
même une question de santé parce que le
chauffage induit des particules fines
est donc celle à semer la bronchiolite
de nos gamins et les maladies
cardiovasculaires de nos aînés qu'est-ce
qu'on attend vous voyez est donc un
nouveau ségur une nouvelle concertation
en fait moi je suis écologiste
depuis quelques années j'entends ça
depuis depuis depuis il n'y a pas de
limite depuis 2002 et jacques chirac
la maison brûle et nous regardons est
d'accord donc on a bien compris même si
vous êtes pour la limitation de la
vitesse là il faut accélérer la
comprendre sur le reste du casting est
ce que vous deux du gouvernement
castex est-ce que vous avez des choses à
dire il ya beaucoup de polémiques
évidemment née autour de la nomination
de gérald darmanin visait d'une part une
plainte pour viol
et puis également eric dupond-moretti ce
que vous comprenez les mois que ça
suscite non seulement je comprends mais
je le partage moi je suis scandalisée si
vous voulez la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et l'égalité
salariale était censée être la grande
cause du quinquennat une position qui
évidemment au partage il ya tant de
retard ça fait ça doit faire 40 ans
qu'on avait inscrit dans la loi roudy
qu'à travail égal salaire égal ça n'a
pas bougé véritablement fondamentalement
en 30 ou 40 ans j'ai discuté il ya
quelques mois avec yvette roudy
justement qui nous disaient mais c'est
pas croyable comme ça ne progresse pas
là encore tout l'attirail législatif est
là la loi du 4 août 2014
le fait de pouvoir sanctionner des
entreprises qui sont en dehors des clous
ça n'est pas fait il ya pas de
transparence sur sur ces questions et
donc vous doutez que gérald darmanin ou
eric dupond-moretti porte cette cette
cause je sais que c'est pas du tout leur
cause
le problème est que ça envoie un signal
encore plus nocifs c'est on sait que
c'est très difficile pour des femmes
victimes de porter plainte parce
qu'elles sont mal reçus dans les
commissariats il ya eu il ya une
hypocrisie complète autour du du
grenelle des violences faites aux femmes
mais la réalité c'est ça quand vous êtes
victime
vous êtes très mal reçus dans les
commissariats c'est si vous venez de
subir un traumatisme
eh bien vous en subissez malheureusement
un autre parce qu'on vous juge sur
comment vous était habillé peut-être que
vous l'avez bien cherché c'est
scandaleux et l'autre problème c'est la
justice et le fait de pouvoir
sanctionner les les violeurs et des
agresseurs on sait qu'il ya
malheureusement assez peu de femmes qui
portent plainte parce que justement
elles savent qu'à la fin la justice ne
sanctionne pas et donc pourquoi vous
infligez le passage au commissariat et
le passage en justice et donc métro
ministère de l'intérieur quelqu'un qui
est poursuivi pour viols et qui a
reconnu quelque part que oui
il pouvait négocier des actes sexuels
il me semble qu'il avait il avait dit
oui tout à fait je les fais on avait eu
ce matin qu'il a droit à la présomption
d'innocence il à la présomption
d'innocence
jeudi qu'il était poursuivi pour viol
simplement envoyer ce signal qu'au
ministère de l'intérieur en gros ne
prendra pas le sujet à bras le corps et
que à la justice on a aussi dupond
moretti qui n'est pas un féministe
clairement disons le comme ça
et bien c'est envoyer un signal
profondément néfaste pour les droits des
femmes et on va passer aux questions
d'actualité julien et le groupe pierre
et vacances qui renonce à son projet
controversé de center pacs de saintes
heures parc à royon roybon dans l'isère
vu arriver est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle oui c'est une très très bonne
nouvelle je voudrais saluer la toute
l'action des militants et des militantes
d'où qu'ils viennent
qu'ont permis cette victoire qui ont
occupé le site c'est aussi les élus
régionaux qui ont multiplié les
batailles dans l'hémicycle de vers
rhône-alpes les batailles en justice
également les élus et puis la population
qui dit en fait il faut arrêter cette
artificialisation des sols c'est encore
en engagement de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat s'est encore un
engagement du président qui n'est pas
tenue il encore une fois ici engagés
lors de la convention citoyenne pour
l'émission regardez simplement ce qu'ils
font là victoire c'est les écolos sur le
terrain et c'est dix ans de procédure et
malheureusement il ya d'autres projets
j'aimerais dire un mot sur center parcs
sur à quel point c'est scandaleux parce
que donc c'est défricher la nature pour
en fabriquer une artificielle quand même
donc vous perdez toute la biodiversité
est fondamentalement personne ne le sait
mais c'est financé avec nos impôts
c'est à dire que tout le modèle de ses
centres de vacances en fait ces fines
hanches et financé avec une niche
fiscale quasiment dédié qui ne sert qu'à
ça
et donc c'est de la défiscalisation pour
les plus riches pour aller faire du
bungalow qui détruit la nature veille et
donc ça ne fonctionne pas le modèle
économique si ça n'est pas basée sur la
défiscalisation est donc là il ya
vraiment fondamentalement un lien à quoi
sert nos impôts si ce n'est en gros à
favoriser la destruction de la nature
nos impôts doivent
servir au bien commun et la protection
de la biodiversité la protection de les
habitats sauvages est un bien commun que
nos impôts doivent préserver et skier
pas je fais le lien avec les 50
propositions qu'on fait le sénat qu'avec
senna sur le plein exercice des libertés
locales l'environnement on sait que
c'est très centralisé et finalement la
politique environnementale mais ce qu'il
faut pardonner plus de pouvoir justement
aux aux élus locaux sur ces domaines là
pour réagir plus vite sur des sujets
tels que celui cité
fondamentalement il faut permettre une
protection une protection accrue de de
l'environnement de la biodiversité et
ensuite offrir effectivement aux maires
et aux régions je pense en matière
d'aménagement du territoire c'est les
régions l'élection locale et j'en veux
dire même les anciennes
parce que la réforme de 2014 vraiment a
plutôt abîmé le paysage qu'autre chose
mais ce sont les régions le bon échelon
pour l'aménagement du territoire et donc
permettre de protéger ces espaces de
créer des parcs naturels régionaux
permettre aussi que chacun chacune
puisse profiter de ce bien commun qui
est la forêt où les espaces naturels et
les protéger et les mettre aussi en
valeur pour permettre un tourisme plus
durable tout ça tout ça correspond à un
intérêt bien compris
encore une fois sociales
environnementales et puis et puis
économique mais justement puisqu'on
parle d'élus locaux et d'aménagement du
territoire l'autre actualité ce sont ces
suppressions de lignes aériennes
lorsqu'il est possible de rejoindre une
destination en train à moins de 2h30
c'est une demande notamment des
écologistes on devrait réagir à ce tweet
de la sénatrice josiane cos sénatrice du
cantal qui dit suppression de la ligne
aérienne clairement orly un mauvais
signal envoyé pour le désenclavement de
l'auvergne si on ajoute les difficultés
liées aux suppressions actuel de train
notamment vers le cantal on va vers une
aggravation de la fracture territoriale
qu'est ce que vous dit je connaissais
pas cette parlementaire mais c'est
fascinant à quel point son tweet dit
tout c'est à dire que qui prend l'avion
aujourd'hui en fait très peu de gens
c'est la classe la plus aisée
alors que tout le monde prend le train
oui et donc son combat c'est compliqué
de par son combat elle avait son combat
elle ça devrait être de défendre le bien
commun et
j'en veux dire les grandes masses la
classe moyenne et classes populaires et
donc son combat ça devrait de soutenir
le train qu on en arrête avec ses
difficultés qu'on arrête de supprimer
des trains que l'on arrête de supprimer
des petites lignes qu'on arrête c'est un
confort des lignes du quotidien plutôt
que de soutenir les mais savait très
bien que les lignes elles ont été
sacrifiés au profit du tgv elles sont
pareils sont souvent en mauvais état
c'était une erreur c'est terrible
c'était une erreur et donc il faut
revenir dessus tout simplement
et donc quand on soutient l'avion on
défavorise le train c'est mathématique
il n'y a pas deux en même temps là
dessus et donc oui nous nous voulons
fortement désavantagées l'avion pour
fortement avantager le train et le train
du quotidien pas les délires de de
liaison aéroport qui concerne que
quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes et les plus aisés ou les
houles et où les hommes d'affaires les
trains du quotidien en ile de france
c'est par exemple le rer b
un million de personnes et pas comme le
vrai pécresse ou d'autres des transports
entre paris et l'aéroport pour 30000
personnes et un million de personnes
trente mille personnes nous faisons le
choix des transports du quotidien donc
ce clermont paris- rénovant le
améliorant le facilitons la cadence
rendant le plus confortable c'est
possible mais c'est un choix politique
et si vous faites le choix de soutenir
l'avion eh bien vous faites le choix de
défavoriser le train et donc du plus
grand nombre de la population alors
autre sujet mais jean castex le nouveau
premier ministre s'est exprimé devant
les parlementaires et hier il ya un
message qui re qui ressort c'est
notamment c'est que d'une part
la relance du dialogue retraites chômage
dépendance relance tout serait remis sur
la table d'île dit jean castex là aussi
est ce que vous y croyez
écoutez ce gouvernement porter une
réforme des retraites qui était injuste
et pas financé si vous souvenez quand
même on a eu toutes les peines du monde
moi j'aimerais savoir par exemple à
titre de citoyens si cette réforme était
appliquée combien je toucherai à l'issue
de ma vie professionnelle ça n'était pas
possible donc parce que pourquoi parce
qu'en fait c'est une lubie il était
parti bille en tête sur cette idée qu'il
fallait réformer parce que ça faisait
bien sûr le pape y étiez pas
complètement défavorable complètement
réforme complètement complètement l'idée
je vais pas revenir sur la réforme à
point l'idée est peut-être 10 la
suppression des rumeurs calcium et
dernier dans ces cas là et au flanc non
parce qu'en fait une
la question c'est de prendre en compte
la pénibilité du travail et donc si vous
me dites on fait une réforme qui prend
en compte la pénibilité du travail
par exemple les caissiers les caissières
si on leur dit mais d'accord dans ce cas
là vous vous avez plus de points par
trimestre voyez la question ce n'est pas
l'uniformité parce que votre travail le
mien et celui d'une personne qui qui est
question les chantiers toute la journée
n'est pas le même et donc moi j'avais
une profonde aversion pour l'hypocrisie
des manuels macron qui disait je n'aime
pas le mot de pénibilité parce que ça
donne le sentiment que le travail est
pénible mais oui il ya des travaux qui
sont plus pénibles et donc dans ces cas
là il faut permettre un départ à la
retraite plus tôt parce que l'enjeu
n'est pas l'espérance de vie mais c'est
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé et sur
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé il ya
une profonde inégalité selon les métiers
que vous avez fait et cet équilibre du
système quand jean castex d'hier devant
les sénateurs que refusé de s'attaquer à
la réforme des retraites c'est assez
irresponsable parce que l'équilibré du
système serait compromis est ce qu'il
n'a pas raison mais je ne crois pas je
crois pas il me semblait que les
différents rapports se contredisent les
équilibres cette année de 30 milliards
que si on était passé à la réforme des
retraites à points notamment
indexés sur des investissements en
bourse évidemment là pour le coup les
retraites et les pensions étaient
carrément en danger voyez donc un moment
il faut s'interroger ce qui ne
fonctionne pas en temps de crise et bien
en fait il faut pas il en faut pas du
tout il faut il nous faut un système qui
est robuste qui appuyée sur la la la la
pardon les fonds publics si vous confiez
à des fonds d'investissements vos
pensions et que ces fonds
d'investissement font faillite
où sont vos pensions oui c'est quand
même lunaire qu'après un discours aussi
lyrique en avril que le président ne dit
plus rien ne sera comme avant
la santé doit sortir du tout marché et
l'environnement c'est pareil et ainsi de
suite
on lui disait en fait on revient avec
cette réforme des retraites où l'idée
sous jacente et la capitalisation et le
fait de confier vos retraites à des
fonds d'investissement qui vont spéculer
avec et risquer de tout perdre
voilà l'enjeu cela dit vous êtes
d'accord que encore une fois il faut
trouver une solution à l équilibre
financier alors est sûre elle nous a
fait des propositions là dessus je
regrette qu'elle n'ait pas été entendu
laquelle par exemple la plus celle de
sortir du tout travail pour le
l'assiette des cotisations et notamment
de faire contribuer le capital au
financement des retraites alors un
dossier sur lequel quand même le
gouvernement avance et on parlait tout à
l'heure le ségur de la santé un accord
semble très proche avec une augmentation
de 180 euros par mois pour les personnes
non médicaux plus de quinze mille
embauches qui a quand même là une
méthode qui semble porter ses fruits
je m'en réjouis si il me semble qu'on
était à 300 euros il ya encore quelques
semaines c'était la revendication
syndicale et que les syndicats et
certains syndicats demandaient encore
plus je trouve que c'est dommage de
mégoter pardon après le la période qui a
traversé le personnel médical et le
délire de félicitations qu'ils ont reçu
de la part du du gouvernement met donc
en fait à un moment il était question de
de véritablement les augmenter puis
ensuite de leur donner une médaille
et finalement on atterrit sur 180 euros
quand le les syndicats demandent 300 je
trouve dommage de mégoter encore une
fois je le dis comme ça
lesquin favorable et 15 mille embauches
ne permettent pas forcément de revenir
au niveau initial mais évidemment moi je
prends les gains encore une fois je vous
dis s'agit pas d'être dans la posture
tout ce qui va dans le bon sens musulin
nous soutiendrons pour nous il ya un
enjeu fondamental de revoir la question
de l'hôpital non plus comme une machine
à cash c'est la tarification à l'acte
cas d'ailleurs initié jean castex il ya
une dizaine d'années mais l'enjeu c'est
la proximité et le côté humain la
dignité est donc un des enjeux de ce
c'est dur c'est aussi d'en finir tout
simplement avec les fermetures de lits
voilà moi ya trois mois j'étais à
belfort en soutien aux manifestants
locaux qui qui disaient leur amour en
fait à l'hôpital public et le fait qu'il
fallait arrêter de concentrer et
d'éloigner les centres de santé dedecker
de d'agglomération c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est de revoir aussi mais je crois que
les territoires on en parlait hier les
questions de l' agence régionale de
santé tirer les leçons de la crise bien
sûr mieux rémunérer les soignants mais
aussi revoir le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital pour le rendre plus humain et
retrouver la proximité le pouvoir voilà
savoir qu'on a des centres de santé et
des maternités non loin de chez vous
allez on va terminer en parlant de votre
parti julien bayou eric piolle le maire
de grenoble qui dit avoir une stratégie
différente de celle de yannick jadot
décidément les verts n'arrivent pas à
sortir de leurs divisions internes
non non non rassurez vous nous déjà on a
la tête rivés sur les premiers pas de
nos mères ça c'est quand même le plus
important
michel rubio là à marseille fait face à
un héritage on va dire lourds de la part
de la droite et donc c'est les écuries
d'augias jeunes des régions a déclaré
l'état d'urgence climatique à strasbourg
c'est sanuki qui nous importe finalement
ce sont nos mères qui vont appliquer les
préconisations de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat bien plus vite
que le premier ministre s'il est le fait
un jour ensuite l'enjeu ce sont les
régionales confirmé cette implantation
sa structuration dans des régions parce
que c'est là véritablement l'échelon
aménagement du territoire développement
économique
toutes les listes écologistes oui nous
le déciderons j'espère ce week-end mais
ça semble bien partie des listes
écologistes ou des liste union de la
gauche ou d'un candidat d'europe
écologie les verts dans toutes les
régions vertes est ouverte
c'est ce qu'a fait un peu le succès aux
municipales où il y avait des kits
configuration très différentes
c'est vraiment allemand socialiste de
banque ou quelqu'un d'autre de la gauche
soit avec vous en tête enfin bref y'a
pas de nom le jouer à l'affirmation de
liste écologiste de projet écologiste il
pouvait se faire comme à lyon sur dennis
verte et ouverte où comme à besançon en
rassemblement lors largement payé le
lait le point qu emma besançon c'était
deux candidats écologistes à l'aller ça
veut dire qu'il y aura des candidats
écologistes à la tête des tous les
listes régionales et quand il ya des
candidats et des candidates sur un
projet écologiste et ça sera pas
forcément des candidats et les
candidates e élevé si c'est ça votre
question oui mais pour nous l'enjeu se
sait que ce soit des candidats
écologistes et des candidats et donc je
veux pas ce qu'il aimait voyager on
prend quand même l'échec du coup on
prend quand même les choses dans l'ordre
et ensuite il nous reviendra
si nous avons franchi cette marche de
proposer une alternative de rose au pays
alors là encore nous voulons une
candidature écologiste
femmes hommes ne l est ou non mais qu'un
projet fondamentalement écologistes et
donc c'est ça l'enjeu
donc ça veut dire s'ils sont avec vous
c'est derrière vous vous ne serez pas
vous derrière un candidat socialiste
nous soutiendrons une candidature
écologiste c'est ce pour quoi j'ai été
élu en décembre notre équipe de quinze
années à la direction s'y emploie
préparez le mouvement pour être à la
hauteur se dépasser aussi et j'espère
que ces prochaines régionales le
permettront dans différentes régions et
préparer le chemin pour une candidature
écologiste qui joue la gagne qui joue le
fait d'arriver premier ou deuxième au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle offrir une alternative
heureuse à ce statu quo dont on voit
bien qu'ils ne il ne fonctionne pas pour
pour nous il ya beaucoup de monde dans
ce pays qui se sent à juste titre mal
représentés nous voulons travailler un
creuset un projet qui représente ces
différentes aspirations à la justice en
fait en fin de compte et donc différents
candidats peuvent se préparer c'est très
bien nous organiserons le cadre et je
peux vous donner portrait robot de la
personne qui gagnera c'est celle qui
jouera le plus collectif
très rapidement la députée delphine
batho a proposé une primaire pour la
présider la prochaine présidentielle qui
concernerait tous les candidats qui ceux
qui ceux qui veulent mettre l'écologie
au pouvoir je reprends son expression
vous êtes favorable
on va discuter de en temps utile nous
aurons un calendrier à vous présenter à
l'automne
la désignation voilà je veux pas
m'avancer et présenter des décisions
mais la diminuation elle aura lieu après
les régionales par un vote et avant
avant l'été avant l'été 2000 2005
imprimer les aurons nous aurons un vote
des adhérents et des adhérentes et
peut-être un vote plus large
je veux pas préempter de ces questions
de calendrier encore une fois aussi tout
simplement parce que le temps n'est pas
encore à la présidentielle puisqu'il ya
des régionales
et puisque d'abord et en premier lieu de
l'enjeu c'est répondre à la crise qui
monte économique et social ce que ne
sait pas le gouvernement
moi j'attendais des mots et des actes
sur les questions
de crise du logement on sait qu'il ya
des personnes qui risquent d'être
expulsés à partir du 10 juillet je
n'entends pas véritablement de mots
rassurants
j'entends même là dessus un rien n'y a
même pas de mots et si on environnement
ya des mots mais nous la prolongation du
moratoire sur le les évacuations wii est
avancé fondamentalement sur les
questions de logement d'abord et sur le
fait de huy de travailler véritablement
ces questions de mal logement et de
précarité énergétique
et ça passe par la rénovation thermique
et c'est fini merci beaucoup merci bien
vaio d'avoir été avec nous merci julien
demain à votre place ce sera ce seront
deux maires de nouveaux maires dont un
maire écologiste pierre hurmic le
nouveau maire éconologis écologistes de
bordeaux et mathieu klein le maire
socialiste de nancy ça sera fait tout de
suite on passe au club des territoires